الغرب يعلنها كنا نعلم اننا سنصل الى هذا
الموقف وعلى اوكرانيا تقديم تنازلات
النتنياهو يرفض وقف اطلاق النار والفصائل
تعلق الافراج عن الاسر ايمانو مكرون
يتراجع عن تصريحه خوف ام ذكاء وسفينه
مساعدات تركيه اخرى تتجه نحو القطاع بعد
رفض تلبيب واشنطن تؤكد ان القطاع سيعود
لشعبه خطه الفصائل الاقتصاديه بدات منذ
عامين الامين العام للامم المتحده يطالب
ايران بالتدخل اوروبا تغلي لاجل القطاع
واوكرانيا تشكو سخريه النيتو والغرب يصب
جام غضبه على قياده كيف هل من هدنه قريبه
يخفت الحديث عن المعارك والاشتباكات لتعلو
مطالب تحرير الاسرى و نتنياهو يصرح في
مقابله مع شبكه سي ان ان بان تل ابيب لن
توافق على وقف اطلاق نار شامل ودائم في
القطاع الا مقابل اطلاق سرح الاس لكنها
مستعده
لهدني محليه وقصيره الامد من جانبها افادت
وكاله رايترز ان الفصائل علقت المفاوضات
بشان المحتجزين العبريين بسبب التصرفات
العبريه حول مجمع الشفاء الطبي لياتي
الدور على مستشار الامن القومي في البيت
الابيض جيك سوليفان الذي اكد ان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن لن يهدا له بال حتى يتم
التوصل الى اتفاق بين تلبيب والفصائل
يتضمن اطلاق سراح الرهائن من القطاع ان
سولفن عادل يقول بان البيت الابيض يشدد
على ان تلبيب يجب ان تتبع قواعد الحرب
اثناء العمليات العسكريه داخل القطاع في
سياق اخر اكد البيت الابيض ايضا ان الشعب
الفلسطيني هو من سيقرر شكل الحكم مستقبلا
في القطاع ويقول ان واشنطن مخرطه في
مفاوضات اطلاق سرح المحتجزين لدى الفصائل
بدوره اتجه الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطوني وترش بحديثه نحو ايران ليحث سلطاته
على حمل الفص على اطلاق سراح الاسرى ومنع
مقامه لبنان من التدخل في الصراع مع تل
ابيب في المقابل وبعد تحميله تل ابيب
مسؤوليه تعمد ايذاء المدنيين الابرياء في
القطاع تراجع الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
ماكرون عن تصريحاته التي اثارت ضجه في تل
ابيب ما الذي حدث ليغير ماكون موقفه
الاجابه لكم ونقل نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي دمتري مدفيدف ان اوروبا تغلي ومئات
الالاف يتظاهرون احتجاجا على الدعم الغربي
لاعمال العنف في القطاع ليعلن السفير
التركي في مصر ارسال سفينه تحمل 600 طن من
المساعدات الى القطاع في الاقتصاد اكدت
صحيفه وول ستريت جورنال ان الفصائل تحولت
للعملات المشفره كملاذ للتمويل في العامين
السابقين لهجومها على تل ابيب وافاد تقرير
للصحيفه ان المخابرات العبريه رصدت منذ
2021 عشرات ملايين الدولارات في محافظ
ماليه مرتبطه بالفصائل لازلنا في الشرق
الاوسط لكن بعيدا عن الحرب او قد يكون هذا
متعلقا بالحرب من يدري حيث اعلنت القياده
العسكريه الامريكيه في اوروبا ان خمسه
جنود امريكيين لقوا حتفهم فيحدث تحطم
طائره عسكريه اثناء التزود بالوقود في
الجو شرقي البحر الابيض
المتوسط صدمه غير
متوقعه ان كنت لا تدري فتلك مصيبه وان كنت
تدري فالمصيبه اعظم ونقلت قناه ذا هيل تي
في الامريكيه في تقريرها كنا نعلم اننا
سنصل الى هذا الموقف حيث يتعين على روسيا
واوكرانيا بدء المفاوضات مضيفه انه من
المحتمل ان تضطر اوكرانيا الى تقديم
تنازلات اقليميه ليخرج ضابط المخابرات
العسكريه الامريكيه السابق سكوت ريتر
مصرحا بان الدول الغربيه تبحث بنشاط عن
خيارات لرفض مساعده الرئيس الاوكراني
فلاديمير زيلينسكي لانها تدرك انه خاسر في
في الصراع مع روسيا واضاف ان الدول
الغربيه فشلت في تحقيق هذا الهدف لذلك لم
تعد بحاجه الى زيلينسكي واوكرانيا في
المقابل اعتبر ميخائيل بدليا مستشار
الرئيس الاوكراني ان بلاده ليست بحاجه
لعروض تفترض التخلي عن جزء من اراضيها
مقابل ضمانات وعضويه في النيتو وانما الى
مساعده عسكريه كامله وذلك بعد تقارير
للنيو وصفتها كييف بالخره اكدت ان على
اوكرانيا تتفاوض بحدودها الحاليه لتعود
صحيفه فاينانشال تايمز الامريكيه وتنقل عن
مصادر في البنتاجون قولها انها اضطرت
لتقليص الدعم المقدم لاوكرانيا بعد
استنفاد
95% من الاموال المخصصه لذلك بينما افادت
وسائل اعلام غربيه بان الغرب انتقد
القياده الاوكرانيه لخسارتها معدات عسكريه
باهضه الثمن لحلف النيتو في هجوم فاشل على
المناطق الروسيه المحصنه واشارت الوسائل
الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه تلقت كل ما قد
يكون ضروريا لاختراق الجبهه الدبابات
والمدفعيه والاسلحه الاخرى الالمانيه
والبريطانيه والامريكيه ميدانيا اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تكبيد الجيش
الاوكراني اكثر من
695 قتيلا وجريحا واسقاط 42 مسيره
اوكرانيه على مختلف المحاور خلال 24 ساعه
حسب وكاله
سبوتنيك
[موسيقى]